okay I told you last week earlier this
week that coinciding with Dennis
Rodman's latest visit to North Korea we
also saw the release of otto warmbier
otto warmbier is an American student who
was arrested in North Korea for
allegedly stealing a poster a propaganda
poster from a North Korean hotel the
North Korean government agreed to
release him basically within hours of
Dennis Rodman's arrival for his latest
trip to North Korea so far we are told
that that was mere coincidental merely
coincidental in terms of the timing we
learned upon otto warmbier x' release
that he had been in a coma in North
Korea dating all the way back to March
of 2016 or about 15 months and we
learned over the last few hours that
otto warmbier has died now back in the
United States in Ohio near his family
this is just a horrible story the North
Korean government claimed he suffered
food poisoning had botulism lost
consciousness after being given a
sleeping pill unfortunately doctors here
in the u.s. found no evidence whatsoever
of botulism having been in his system to
the extent that that's possible to do
retro actively on at the same time they
found no evidence of physical abuse
insofar as there was not evidence of
healed fractures for example you
wouldn't necessarily be able to find
evidence of all kinds of physical abuse
at this point but again unclear and now
indeed he has passed away here in the
United States and this more or less
confirms the horrible reality of what we
assumed North Korea was doing which was
the Dennis Rodman thing aside the timing
of that aside they basically realized
that this was someone that was quickly
deteriorating and they did not want him
dying on North Korean soil it really is
a tragedy and rare credit to Donald
Trump here for showing some reserve and
responding to this yeah because he said
you know it's great that oughta was able
to go home to his family for his final
days and you know we'll find a way to
handle North Korea really no president
has been able to do that especially
because they have nuclear weapons right
and striking distance to Seoul but it's
just the latest chapter although it so
yes Trump did seem to show some degree
of restraint but at the same time he
also slammed Obama saying hey otto
warmbier has been in North Korea since
Barack Obama was president and he didn't
do enough to get him out blah blah blah
of course this ignores the fact that
there are other Americans still in North
Korea who have been there for a while
why hasn't Trump gotten that out if he's
the great savior of people who get stuck
in North Korea and undoubtedly and this
is too bad but I'm sure in the future
more Americans will be held captive and
we'll go in while he's president well
that's what I wanted to ask you about
which is at this point would you go to
North Korea it so to backtrack a little
bit
otto warmbier was in North Korea with a
Chinese based company called young
pioneer tours that company as a result
of this incident has announced they will
no longer take American visitors to
North Korea I guess Chinese visitors to
North Korea are not as at risk of this
type of propagandistic detainment as
Americans are we interview a few years
ago this guy's filmmaker named Matt
doors and SiC who went to North Korea on
one of these tours did a great
documentary vises been there we've seen
a number of these documentaries the
truth is every time you go into North
Korea particularly to record
surreptitiously audio or video you're
taking a major risk and Americans are at
risk we have other instances of
Americans of more you know high-profile
incidents like these that have taken
place would you go to North Korea I
would only go to the joint security area
which is that room along the 38th
parallel that's shared by both the North
and South Koreans but you then join the
South node enter from the South I think
you go to the north side of the room but
that would be about it for me yeah so
basically your answer is no yes I would
love to go I mean it would be
fascinating but honestly I would wonder
given my track record of years of year
and years of criticizing North Korea
would they be aware of my views would
they conspire to detain me after
approving me for a visa I think I would
probably be at risk I mean most of the
people there wouldn't be able to look up
the videos on the Internet no but I'm
but reservedly kim jeong-hoon would be
able to right yeah I think I probably
wouldn't go although I would I would
love to and I think it would be
endlessly fascinating
I think for my own safe safety it would
be a bad idea to go and same question
kind of comes up given my long track
record of comments about Russia like
would it even be safe to go to Russia I
would certainly be what's considered a
political dissident there we know how
they treat them would they would would I
end up accidentally stabbing myself in
the back ten times or something like
that who knows